The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Let's get started.
So what I'm going to do next
is switch gears to one
interesting compiler, which
is the StreamIt
parallelizing compiler.
The main idea about StreamIt
is the need for a common
machine language.
What we want to do normally is,
in a language, you want to
represent common architecture
properties so you get good
performance.
You don't do it at a very high
level of abstraction, so you
base a lot of cycles dealing
with the abstraction.
But you want to abstract out
the differences between
machines to get the portability,
otherwise you are
going to just do
assembly-hacking for one machine.
Also you can't have things too
complex, because a typical
programmer cannot deal with very
complex things that we
ask them to do.
C and Fortran was a really nice
common assembly language
for imperative languages
running
on the unicore machines.
The problem is this type of
language is not a good common
language for multicores, because
it doesn't deal with,
first of all, multiple cores.
And as you keep changing
the number of cores --
for example, automatic
parallelizing compilers are
not good to basically get really
good parallelism out of
that, even though we
talk about that.
Still a lot of work has
to be done in there.
So what's the correct
abstraction if you have
multicore machines?
The current offering, what you
guys are doing, is things like
OpenMP, MPI type stuff.
You are hand-hacking
the parallelism.
Well, the issue with that.
It's basically this explicit
parallel construct.
It's kind of added to languages
like C -- that's
what you're working on.
And what this does is all these
nice properties about
composability, malleability,
debuggability, portability --
all those things were kind
of out of the window.
And this is why this
parallelizing is hard, because
all these things makes life
very difficult for the
programmer.
And it's a huge additional
program burden.
The programmer has to introduce
parallelism,
correctness, optimization --
it's all left to
the programmer.
So what the program has to do in
this kind of world -- what
you are doing right now --
you have to feed all the
granularity decisions.
If things are too small
you might get too much
communication.
If things are too large you
might not get good load
balancing, and stuff like.
And then you deal with all the
load balancing decisions.
All those decisions are
left for you guys.
You need to figure out what's
local, what's not.
And if you make a wrong decision
it can cost you.
All the synchronization, and
all the pain and suffering
that comes from making
a wrong decision.
Things like race conditions,
deadlocks,
and stuff like that.
And this, while MIT students can
hack it, you can't go and
convince a dull programmer to
convert from writing nice
simple Java application code
to dealing with all these
complexities.
So this is what kind of led to
our research for the last five
years to do StreamIt.
What you want to do is move a
bunch of these decisions to
the compiler.
Granularity, load balancing,
locality, and
synchronization --
[OBSCURED]
And in today's talk I am going
to talk to you about, after
you write a StreamIt program
-- as Bill pointed out, the
nice parallel properties -- how
do you actually go about
getting this kind
of parallelism.
So in StreamIt , in summary, it
basically has regular and
repeating computation
in these filters.
This is called a synchronous
data flow model, because we
know at compile time exactly how
the data moves, how much
each produces and consumes.
And this has natural
parallelism, and it exposes
exactly what's going to happen
to the compiler.
And the compiler can do a lot
of powerful transformations,
as yesterday I pointed out.
The first thing is, because of
synchronous data flow, we know
at compile time exactly who
needs to do what when.
And that really helps
transform.
It's not like everything happens
run-time dynamically.
So what does that mean?
So what that means is each
filter knows exactly how much
to push and pop --
that's in a repeatable
execution.
And so what we can do is, we
can come up to the static
schedule that can be repeated
multiple times.
So let me tell you a little
bit about what a static
schedule means.
So assume this filter pushes
two, this filter pops three
but pushes one, that
filter pops two.
So these are kind of rate
pushes, it's not everybody
producing-consuming at once.
So what's the schedule?
So you can say --
OK, at the beginning it produces
two items, but I
can't consume that because I
need three items. And then I
do two of them, and I can
consume the first three and
then produce one there.
And I have two left behind.
I do one more that, and
now I got three.
And it consumes that
and produces that.
And then I can fire C. So the
neat thing about this is, when
I started there was nothing
inside any of these buffers.
And if I ran A, A, B, A, B, C,
there's nothing inside the
buffers again.
So what I have is, I'm back to
the starting positioning.
And if I repeat this millions
of times --
I keep the computation running
nicely without any buffers
accumulating or anything
like that.
So I can come up with this very
nice schedule that says
-- here's what I have to do.
I have to run A actually three
times, B twice, and C once, in
this order, and if I
do that I have a
computation that keeps running.
And that gives me a good global
view on what can I
parallelize, what can I load
balance, all those things.
Because things don't change.
One more additional thing about
StreamIt is we can look
at more elements than
I am consuming.
Question?
AUDIENCE: How common is it in
your typical code that you can
actually produce a static
schedule like that?
PROFESSOR: In a lot of DSV
code this is very common.
A lot of DSV code right now that
goes into hardware and
software, they have very
common properties.
But even things that are not
common, what has a very large
chunk of the program has this
static property, and there are
some few places that has
dynamic property.
So it's like, when you write a
normal program you don't write
a branch instruction after
every instruction.
You have a few hundred
instructions and a branch, a
few tens of instructions and
a branch type thing.
So what you can think about it
is that those instructions
without a branch can get
optimized the hell out of
them, and then you do a
branch dynamically.
So you can think about
it like this.
What's the largest chunks you
can find that you don't have
this uncertainty
until run-time?
Then you can optimize the hell
out of it, and then you can
deal with this run-time
issues --
basically branches, or control
for changes, or direct your
rate changes at run-time.
If we have 10-90 rule, if you
get 90% of the things are in a
nice thing, and if you get good
performance on that --
hey, it has a big impact.
So in our language you can deal
with dynamism, but our
analysis is basically trying
to find the largest static
chunk and analyze.
So most of the time that
basically said we start with
empty and end with empty.
But the trouble is, a lot of
times we actually can look
beyond the number of
what we consume.
So what you have to do is kind
of do initial schedule that
you don't start with empty,
you basically consume
something -- you start with
something like this.
So the next time in
something comes --
three things come
into this one --
I can actually pick four
and pop three.
So you go through the first
thing kind of priming
everything with the amount of
data needed, and then you go
to the static schedule.
This kind of gives you a feel
for what you'll get.
This is a neat thing,
I know exactly
what's going on in here.
So now how do I run
this parallelism?
This is something actually
Rodric pointed out before,
there are three types of
parallelism we can deal with.
So here's my stream program in
here, and I do some filters,
scatter-gather in here.
The first site of parallelism
is task parallelism.
What that means is the
programmer said, there are
three things that can
run parallelly
before I join them together.
So this is a
programmer-specified
parallelism.
And you have a nice data
parallel messenger
presentation.
The second part is
data parallelism.
What that means is, you have
some of these things that
don't depend on the previous
run of that one.
So there's no invocation,
dependency across multiple
invocations.
These are called stateless
filters, there's no state that
keeps changing.
If the state kept changing,
you had to wait till the
previous one finishes
to run the next one.
So if you have a stateless
filter --
assume that it's data
parallel --
what you can do is you can
basically take that, replicate
it many, many times, and
when the data comes --
parallel is in it
every data --
and it will compute and
parallelly get out here.
The final thing is pipeline
parallelism.
So you can feed this one into
this one, this one into this
one, and then douse across
in a pipeline fashion.
And you can get multiple
things execution.
So we have these three types
of parallelism in here, and
the interesting thing is if you
have stateful filters, you
can't run this data parallel.
Actually the only parallelism
you can get is pipeline
parallelism.
So traditionally task
parallelism is fork/join
parallelism, that you guys
are doing right now.
Data parallelism is
loop parallelism.
And pipeline parallelism mainly
was done in hardware.
If you have done something like
Verilog or VHDL you'll do
a lot of pipeline parallelism.
So kind of combining these three
ideas from different
communities all into one,
because I think programs can
have each part in there.
So now, how do you go
and exploit this?
How do you go take advantage
of that?
So I'll talk a little bit of
baseline techniques, and then
talk about what StreamIt
compiler does today.
So assume I have a program
like this.
The hardest thing is there
are two tasks in here.
The programs are given, you
don't have to worry anything
about that.
And what you can do is assign
them into different
cores and run it.
Neat.
You can think what a fork /join
parallelism is, you come
here you fork, you do this
thing, and you join in here.
So the interesting thing is
if you have two cores.
You probably got a 2x
speedup in this one.
This is really neat because
there are two things in here.
The problem is, how about if you
have a lot more different
number of cores?
Or if the next generation has
double the number of cores,
and I'm stuck with the program
you've written for the current
generation?
So this not that great,
interesting.
So we ran it on the Raw
processor we have -- it has 16
cores in there --
that we have been building, and
this is actually running a
simulator of that.
What you find is, is a bunch of
StreamIt programs we have
we kind of get performance like
basically close to two,
because that's the kind of
parallelism people have written.
In fact, some programs even
slowed down in there, because
what happens in here is
the parallelism and
synchronization is not matched
with the target --
because it's matched
with the program.
Because you wrote a program
because your parallelism in
there was what you thought was
right for the algorithm.
We didn't want you to give any
consideration to the machine
you are running, and it didn't
match the machine, basically,
if you just got the
parallelism.
And you just don't
do that right.
So one thing we have noticed
for a lot of streaming
programs, to answer your
question, is there are a lot
of data parallelism.
In fact, in this filter --
in this program --
what you can do is you can find
data parallel filters,
and parallelize them.
So you can take each
filter, run it on
every core for awile.
Get the data back.
Go to the next filter,
write on every
go-while, get that back.
So what you can do is, if you
have four cores in here, you
can each replicate all
this four times.
Run these four for a while,
and then these four, these
four, these four, these four.
OK?
So that's the nice
way to do that.
So the nice thing about doing
that is you have a lot of nice
in the load balancing, because
each are doing the same amount
of work for a while.
And after it accumulates enough
data you go to the next
one, do for a while,
and then like that.
And each group basically will
occupy the entire machine --
you just go down this
group like that.
And so we ran it, it started
even slower.
Why?
It should have a lot more
parallelism, because all those
filters were data-parallel.
So you sort of gettting stuck
with two, now we can easily
run a parallelism of 16, because
data parallelism you
can just put it any
amount in there.
But we are running slow.
AUDIENCE: Communication
overhead?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it could
mainly be communication
overhead, because what happens
is you run this for a small
amount of time.
You had to send it all over
the place, collect it back
again, send it all over the
place, collect it back again.
The problem is there's too
much synchronization and
communication.
Because every person at the
end is like this global
barrier, and the data has
to go shuffling around.
And that doesn't help.
So the other part, what you can
do in the baseline is what
you call hardware pipeline.
What that means is you can
actually do pipeline
parallelism.
The way you can do that is you
can look at the amount of work
each filters contain, and you
can combine them together in a
way that the number of filters
is going to be just about the
number of tiles available.
Most programs have
more filters than
the number of cores.
So you review combined filters,
to give us a number
of filters, is just either the
same, or one or two less than
the number of cores available.
In a way that you combine them
so each of them will probably
have close to the same
amount of work.
The problem is if when you
combine it's very hard to get
the same amount of work.
And if you assume eight cores,
you can do this combination
and we can say --
aha, if I do this combination,
I have one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven.
Eight cores, I can get
seven of them.
Hopefully each of them have the
same amount of work, and I
can run that.
And then we assign this to one
filter and say -- "You own
this one, you run it forever.
You get the data from the guy
who owns this one, and you
produce at this one." And if
you have more cores you can
actually keep doing
some of that.
If you have enough filters
you can each
combine them and do that.
So we perform, and
we got this.
Not that bad.
So what might be the
problems here?
AUDIENCE: Hardware locality.
You want to make sure that the
communicating filters are
close to each other.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, that
we can deal with.
It's not a big locality
[OBSCURED]
What's the other problem?
The bigger problem.
AUDIENCE: [NOISE]
load balance.
PROFESSOR: Load balance is the
biggest problem, because the
problem is you are combining
different types of things
together, and you are hoping
that each chunk you get
combined togeher will
have an almost
identical amount of work.
And that's very hard to achieve
most of the time,
because dynamically things
keep changing.
The nice thing about loops is,
most of the time if you have a
loop or state if you replicate
it many times, it's the same
amount of code, same
amount of work.
It nicely balances out.
Hardware --
combining different things
becomes actually much harder.
So again, parallelism and
synchronization are not really
matched to the target.
So the StreamIt compiler right
now does two, three things.
I'll go through details.
Coarsen the granularity
of things.
So what happens is if you have
small filters it combines them
together to get the large
stateless areas.
It data parallelizes
when possible.
And it does software pipelining,
that's a pipeline
parallelism.
I'll go through all these
things in detail.
And you can get about
11x's speedup by
doing all those things.
So coarsen the stream graph.
So you look at this stream
graph and say -- wait a
minute, I have a bunch of
data-parallel parts.
And before what I did was I take
each data-parallel part,
when 16 then came or get
together, went 16 came
together, went 16.
Why?
I have put too much
communication.
Can I combine data-parallel
things into one gigantic unit
when possible?
Of course, you don't want to
combine a data-parallel part
with a non-data-parallel part.
Then the entire thing
becomes sequential,
and that's not helpful.
So in here what we found is
these four cannot be combined,
because if you combime them
the entire thing becomes
sequential.
So what we have to do is, you
can combine this way.
So all those things are
data-parallel, all those
things are data-parallel.
And even though they are
data-parallel if you combine
them they become
non-data-parallel, because
this is actually doing peeking,
it's looking at more
than one, and so it's
looking at somebody
else's iteration work.
So you can't combine them.
So what the benefits of doing
this is you reduce global
communication basically.
And the next thing
is you want data
parallelizing to four cores.
And this one fits four
ways in there.
But the interesting thing is,
when you go in this one you
realize there's some
task parallelism.
We know there are two tasks that
have the same amount of
work in here.
So facing this four ways, and
facing this four ways, and
giving the entire machine to
this one, and giving the
entire machine to this one,
might not be the best idea.
What you want to do is you
want to face it two ways.
And then basically give the
entire machine to all of these
running at the same time,
because they're
load balanced --
because they are the same
thing repeated.
And you can do the same
thing in here.
OK.
So that's what the compiler
does automatically, and it
preserves task parallelism.
So if you are task parallelism
you don't need --
the thing about that is the
parallelism you need, you
don't need too much
parallelism.
You need enough parallelism
to make the machine happy.
If you have too much parallelism
you end up in
other problems, like
synchronization.
So this gives enough parallelism
to keep the entire
machine happy, but
not too much.
And by doing that actually we
get pretty good performance.
There are a few cases where this
hardware parallelism wins
out, these two, but
most of them --
actually this last one
we can recover --
do it pretty well.
OK.
So what's left here is -- so
this is good parallelism and
low synchronization.
But there's one thing, when you
are doing data parallelism
there are places where there
are filters that cannot be
parallelized -- they are
stateful filters.
Because you can't run the data
parallelism, and according to
Amdahl's Law that's actually
going to basically kill you,
because that's just waiting
there and you
can't do too much.
I'm going to show that using
this separate program -- so
this number is the amount
of work that each
of them has to do.
So this is actually a lot of
work, a lot of work -- this
does a little work in each
of these filters.
So if you look at that, these
are data parallel but it
doesn't do any much work.
Just parallelizing this
doesn't help you.
And these are data parallel.
And these actually
do enough work.
Actually we can go and say I
am replicating this four
times, and I'm OK.
I'm getting actually good
performance in here.
Now what we have is a
program like this.
And so if you are not doing
anything else that we have
data parallelism in.
So what happens in the first
cycle you run these two.
And then you run data parallel
this one, and then you run
these, and then you run data
parallel this one.
And if you look at that, what
happens is we have a bunch of
holes in here.
Because at that point when you
are running that part of the
program there's not enough
parallelism, and you only have
two things in there.
And when you're running this
you can run this task
parallelism in here, but there's
nothing else you can
do in here.
And so you get basically
21 time steps each --
time minutes basically will
run into that program.
But here we can do better.
What we can do is we can take
and try to move that there,
and kind of compress them.
But the interesting thing
is these things
are not data parallel.
So how do I do that?
So the way to do that is taking
advantage of pipeline
parallelism.
So what you can do is you can
take this filter in here.
Since each of the entire graph
can run only sequentially --
this has to run after this --
you can look at the filters
running separately like that,
and kind of say, instead of
running this and this and this,
why don't I run this
iterations of this one.
This iterations of
this invocation.
And this interations
of this one.
And this iterations
on the next one.
And I'm still maintaining --
because when I'm running this
even though the --
I'm not running anything data
parallel here because these
ones were already done
previously, so I can actually
use that value.
And so I can maintain that
dependency, but I'm running
things from the different
iterations.
And so what I need to do is, I
need to kind of do a prologue
to kind of set everything
up in there.
And then I can do that and
I don't have any kind of
dependence among these things.
So now what I can do is I can
basically take thes two and
basically lay out anything
anywhere in those groups,
because they are in different
iterations and since I am
pipelining these I don't have
any dependence in there.
So I end up in this kind of a
thing, and basically much
compress in here.
And by doing that what you
actually get is a really nice
performance.
The only place that this
actually wins -- hardware
pipelining, and this little
bit in there.
But the rest you get a really
good win in here.
OK.
So what this does is basically
now we got a program that when
the programmer never thought
anything about what the
hardware is --
just wrote abstract graph
and data streaming.
And given Raw, we automatically
actually mapped
into it, and figured out what
is the right balance, right
communication, right
synchronization, and got
really good performance.
And you're getting something
like 11x performance.
If you do hard hand, if you work
hard probably you can do
a little bit better.
But this is good, because you
don't hand-do anything.
The killer thing is now I can
probably take this set of
programs -- which we are
actually working on -- is you
can take them to Cell which has,
depending on the day, six
cores, seven cores, eight cores,
and we can basically
get to matching the number
of cores in there.
So this is it because right now
what happens is you have
to basically hand code all those
things, and this can
automate all that process.
So that's the idea, is can you
do this -- which we haven't
really proved and this
is our research --
write once, use anywhere.
So write this program once
in this abstract way.
You have to really don't think
about full parallelism.
You have to think about some
amount of parallelism, how
this can be put into a stream
graph, but you are not dealing
with synchronization, load
balancing, performance.
You don't have to
deal with that.
And then the compiler will
automatically do all these
things behind you, and get
really good performance.
And the reason I showed
this was --
I'll just play one more
slide I think --
showed this was it's
not a simple thing.
The compiler actually has to do
a bunch of work, the work
that you used to do before.
Things like figuring out what's
the right granularity,
what's the right mix of
operations, what type of
transformations you need
to do to get there.
But at some point we did three
things -- coarse-grained, data
parallel, and software
pipelining.
And by doing these three we can
actually get a really good
performance in most of the
programs we have. So what we
are hoping is basically this
kind of techniques can in fact
help programmers to get
multicore performance without
really going and dealing in the
grunge level of details
you guys do.
You guys will appreciate that,
and hopefully will
think of making --
because now at the end of this
class, you will know all the
pain and suffering the
programmers go
through to get there.
And the interesting thing would
be to in fact look at
the ways to basically reduce
that pain and suffering.
So that's what I have today.
So this was, as I promised,
a short lecture --
the second one.
Any questions?
AUDIENCE: So if we've got enough
data parallelism we'll
have the same software pipeline
jumping on each tile?
Is that right?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So if you do that how does it
scale up to something that has
higher communication
costs than Raw?
By doing this software
pipelining you have to do all
of your communication
off tile.
PROFESSOR: So the interest in
there right now is we haven't
done any kind of hardware
pipelining.
We are kind of doing --
everybody's getting a lot of
data moving in there.
The neat thing about right now
is, even with the SP in Cell
and even Raw, the number of
tiles are still small enough
that a lot of communication
-- unless way too much
communication -- it doesn't
really overwhelm you.
Because everybody's nearby,
you can send things.
They talk a little bit about in
Cell that near enableness
helps, but not that much.
But as we go into larger and
larger cores, it's going to
become an issue.
Near enables become much easier
to communicate, and you
can't do global things
in there.
And at that point you will
actually have to do some
hardware pipelining.
You can't just assume that at
some point everybody's going
to get some data and
go to something.
So what you need to do is have
different chunks that the only
communication that would be
between these chunks would be
kind of a pipeline
communication.
So you don't mix data around.
So as we go into larger and
larger cores you need to start
doing techniques like that.
The interesting thing here is
even though what you had to
change was the compiler --
hopefully the program stays
the same --
right now it's not an easy
issue, because our compiler
has 10 times more core than the
program, so it's easier in
the program.
But if you look at something C,
the core base is millions
of times larger than the
size of the compiler.
So at some point they'll
be switched.
It's easier to change
the compiler to kind
of keep up to date.
That's what happened in C. Every
generation you change
the compiler, you don't ask
programmers where to code the
application.
So can you make these kind of
things as the multicores
become different --
bigger, have different
features.
You change the compiler to get
the performance, but have the
same code base.
That's the goal for
portability.
AUDIENCE: Have you tried
applying StreamIt or the
streaming model in general, to
codes that are not not very
clearly stream-based but using
the streaming model to make
communication explicit, such
as scientific codes.
Or, for example, the kinds of
parallelizable loops that you
covered in the first half
of the lecture.
PROFESSOR: Some of those things,
when you have free
form simple communication
can map into streaming.
So for example, one thing
we are doing is things
like right now MPEG.
Some part of the MPEG is nicely
StreamIt, but when you
actually go inside the MPEG and
dealing with the frame,
it's basically a big array,
and you're doing that.
So how do you chunkify the
arrays, and basically deal
with it in a streaming order?
There's some interesting
things you can do.
There will be some stuff
that doesn't fit that.
Things like pattern recognition
type stuff, where
what you want to do
is you want to --
assume you're trying to --
good example.
You're trying to feature
a condition in a video.
And what happens is the number
of features, can you match or
connect two features,
or match and
connect a thousand features.
And then each feature you need
to do some processing.
And that is a very
dynamic thing.
And that doesn't
really fit into
streaming order right now.
And so the interesting thing is,
the problem we have been
doing is we are trying to
fit everything into one.
So right now the object-oriented
model is it
basically -- everything
has to fit in there.
But what you're finding is there
are many things that
don't really fit nicely.
And you'll do these very crazy
looking things just to get
every program to fit into the
object-oriented model.
That doesn't really work.
I think the right way
to work is, is there
might be multiple models.
There's a streaming model,
there's some kind of a
threaded model, there might
be different ones --
I don't know what other
models are.
So the key thing is your program
might have a large
chunky model, another
chunky model.
Don't try to come up with --
right now what we have
is we have a kitchen
sink type of language.
It tries to support everything
at the same time.
And that doesn't really work
because then you have to think
about and say --
OK done, can I have
a pointer here?
And I need to think about all
the possible models kind of
colliding in the same space.
AUDIENCE: On the other hand, the
object-oriented model is
much more generalized to me.
It's not the best model for
many things, but it's much
more generalizable
than some models.
And having a single model cuts
down on the number of semantic
barriers you have to cross --
PROFESSOR: I don't know but --
AUDIENCE: Semantic barriers
incur both programmer overhead
and run-time overhead.
PROFESSOR: See the problem with
right now with all the
semantic barriers, is
object-oriented model plus a
huge number of libraries.
If you want to do OpenGL, it's
object-oriented but you have
no library.
If you want to do something
else, you have
to learn the library.
What the right thing would be,
instead of trying to learn the
libraries is learn kind
of a subset language.
So you have nice semantics, you
have nice syntax in there,
you have nice error
checking, nice
optimization within that syntax.
Because the trouble is right now
everything is in this just
gigantic language, and you
can't do anything.
And in the program you don't
even know, because you can mix
and match in really bad ways.
The mix and match gives you
a lot of power, but it can
actually really hurt.
And a lot of people
don't need it.
Like for example in C, people
doubt it was really crucial
for you to access any part of
memory anywhere you want.
You just can go and just access
any program, anywhere,
anytime in there.
If you look at it, nobody
takes advantage of that.
How many times do you write the
program an say -- "Hey, I
want to go access the other
guy's stack from this part."
That doesn't work.
You have a variable and
you use a variable.
AUDIENCE: It still [OBSCURED]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, but the thing
is because of that power, it
creates a lot of problems
for a compiler --
because it needs to prove
that you're not doing
that, which is hard.
And also, if you make a mistake
the program is like --
"Yeah, this looks like right.
It still matches my semantics
and syntax, I'll let you do
that." But what you realize is
that's not something people do
-- just stick with
your variable.
And if you don't go
to variables --
that's what type-safe languages
do -- it's probably
more for bugs than a feature.
And the same kind of thing
having efficiency in language,
is you can do everything
at the same time.
Why can't you have a language
that you can go with this kind
of context.
I'm in the streaming
context now.
I say this is my streaming
context.
I am in a threaded context.
Then what that does is, I have
to learn the full set of
features, but I restrict
what I'm using here.
That can probably realistically
improve your
program building, because you
don't have to worry about --
AUDIENCE: It gives the
programmer time to get to know
each language.
PROFESSOR: But right now
you have to do that.
If you look at C# it has
all these features.
It has streaming features, it
has threaded features, it has
every possible object-oriented
feature.
AUDIENCE: Right, but there's a
compact central model which
covers most things.
You can pull in additional
features and fit them
[OBSCURED].
You can do pointer manipulation
in C#, but you
bracket things into
an unsafe block.
And then the compiler knows
in there you're
doing really bad things.
PROFESSOR: That's a nice
thing, because
you can have unsafe.
But can you have something
like -- this is
my streaming part.
OK.
Can I do something like
that, so I don't have
to worry about other?
The key thing is, is there a
way where -- because right
now, my feeling is if you look
at the object-oriented part.
So if you are doing, for
example, Windows programming,
you can spend about a week
and learn all the
object-oriented concepts.
And you have to spend probably
a year to learn all the
libraries on top of that.
That's the old action
these days.
It's basically the building
blocks have become too low,
and then everything else is kind
of an unorganized mess on
top of that.
Can you put more abstraction
things that easy?
Hey, I'm talking about
research, this is
one possible angle.
I mean there might -- you can
think, I know there are messes
that I think in there.
My feeling is what we do well
is when things get too
complicated we build
abstraction layers.
And the interesting thing there
is, we build this high
level programming language
abstraction layer.
And then now we have built so
much crud on top of that
without any nice abstraction
layers, I think it's probably
time to think through what
there could be at the
abstraction level.
Things like, it's hitting --
that is where parallelism
is really hitting.
Because that layer, the
object-oriented layer, doesn't
really support that well.
And it's all kind of ad
hoc on top of that.
And so that says something.
Yes, it's usable.
We had this argument --
assembly languages programmers
-- for two decades.
There are people who were
swearing by assembly languages.
They could write it two times
smaller, two times faster than
anything you can write in
high level language.
It's probably still
true today.
But at the end there were
things that high level
languages won out.
I think we are probably in
another layer like that.
I don't know, probably will
go with that argument.
You can always point to
something saying this is
something you cannot do.
If there are still things --
like structured programs and
unstructured programs,
we talked about that.
That argument went
for a decade.
AUDIENCE: The question I would
pose is can you formulate a
kitchen sink language at a
parallelizable level of
abstraction?
PROFESSOR: Ah.
That's interesting, because
parallelization is -- one of
the biggest things people
have to figure out is
composability.
You can't have two parallel
regions as a
black box put together.
You start running into deadlocks
and all those other
issues in there.
Most of the things that you work
is the abstraction works,
because then you can compose at
a higher level abstraction.
You can have interface and
say -- here are something
interface, I don't know what's
underneath, I compose at the
interface level.
And then the next guy composes
at the higher level, and
everything is hidden.
We don't know how to do that
in parallelism right now.
We need to combine two things,
it runs into problems. And the
minute you figure that one out
-- if somebody can figure out
what's the right abstraction
that is composable, parallel
abstraction --
I think that will solve a
huge amount of problems.
AUDIENCE: Isn't it Fortress that
attempted to do something
that's parallelizable and the
kitchen sink, but that then
leaves all the parallelizable
--
AUDIENCE: I'm saying how
terrible [OBSCURED]
programmers.
PROFESSOR: But I would say right
now is a very exciting
time, because there's
a big problem and
nobody knows the solution.
And I think for industry they
lose a lot of sleep over that,
but for academia it's
the best time.
Because we don't care, we don't
have to make money out
of these things, we don't have
to get production out of it.
But these actually have a very
open problem that a lot of
people care about.
And I think this is fun partly
because of that.
I think this huge open problem
that if you talk to people
like Intels and Microsoft, a
lot of people worry a lot
about they don't know how to
deal with the future in 5-10
years time.
They don't see this is scaling
what they're doing.
And from Intel's point of
view, they made money by
making Moore's Law available
for people to use.
They know how to make it
available, but they don't know
how to make people use it.
From Microsoft's point of
view, their current
development methodology is
almost at this breaking point.
And if you look at the last
time this happening -- so
things like Windows 3.0, where
their current development
methodology doesn't really
scale, and they really
revamped it.
They came up with all this
process, and that had
lasted until now.
For the last two Office and
Vista, just realized they
can't really scale that up.
So they are already in trouble,
because they can't
write the next big goal is just
two times bigger than
Vista, and hopefully
get it working.
But on top of that, they have
it thrown this multicore
thing, and that really puts
huge amount of burden.
So they are worried
about that.
So from both their point of
view, everybody's clamoring
for a solution.
And things like last
time around --
I'll talk about this in the
future -- last time around
when that happened, it created
a huge amount of
opportunities, and bunch of
people who sold it kind of
became famous.
Becuase they say -- we came up
with a solution, and that
people started using and
stuff like that.
Right now, everybody's kind of
waiting for somebody to come
up and say here's the solution,
here's a solution.
And there are a lot of --
Fortress type exports is one,
and what we are doing is one.
And hopefully some of you will
end up doing something
interesting that
might solve it.
This is why it's fun.
I think we haven't had this much
of an interesting time in
programming languages,
parallelism, architecture in
the last two decades.
With that, I'll stop my talk.